hot breath yeah you'll do things like
have a spot on stage to try an
old jer joke versus a new joke and
you'll do anchoring where you're like
connecting words with movements right
you like get into the
grit of this well yeah but every comic
does it though
um they just don't know that they're
doing it
um and then there's a fine line of doing
it on purpose because now you're just
uh like uh it's a small word animatronic
you know it's again it's it's like kung
fu you're like using it when
that was a horrible example but using
when you want and
you know wrong i can name eight billion
comics that have a thing
everybody does when the punch line is
given they do
something and it's the same thing after
every punchline
right so you by the third time
the audience know like subconsciously
knows oh that's where we're supposed to
laugh
you know it's like just like that
horrible you know
three and a half men where after every
joke they go
you're kind of doing the same thing
where every time you get a laugh
you move the mic stand down or you take
drink or if you smoke you you blow out
or you shift or you do it you're doing
if you do that
every time that they laugh you know you
can't have it be something like every
time you get allowed
you know you you go yeah like that right
right there's
there's subtle things that that you can
do that you don't even know you're doing
what are some of the techniques you've
developed over 30 years
of uh doing that type of stuff yeah like
really um
you had started to mention it before
about like you have certain techniques
you'll do on stage
i do um i don't know
boy it seems like so long since we've
been on stage right yeah
uh i'll do a thing where if you know you
ever follow somebody
who's just not your energy or they crush
or they eat it in front of you a lot of
people
i'll ride that wave um regardless of
what they did so if the act in front of
me
was pretty high energy really likable
walked around a lot on stage
i'll get on stage and i will mimic not
mimic or imitate but i'll do that same
energy
for a couple seconds
and then i'll bring it back to me if
it's not you know if the person
kind of talks slow i talk pretty fast if
the person is just more just
just mellow and just talks like this
i'll get on stage and be like
hey guys thanks for coming out but then
then as i start talking i'll start
ramping it up back to me just because i
think
people need that that moment or if
somebody was standing
a certain way on stage or standing in a
certain spot or
holding the mic like this and holding
the top of the mic stand it was just
doing this it was like no you suck
you suck where am i you know just doing
something i'll i'll take the mic and
i'll make sure that i don't stand this
way
for the first until that space is mine
uh-huh
because people because people are used
to
right are useless is seeing that if you
were just on stage
i don't even know um
if you were just going hey all women
should just be pregnant
all women should be pregnant and only
make sandwiches
and right ladies uh what right i'm just
thinking really horrible things in
stores
then i then i get on stage
right
you're still thinking oh that i just
said
when i gave words to that breath